i'm here in the kitchen with my culinary
partner in crime chef laura valdez
that's right
i love you love you all right it's
tuesday in october and here on the drew
barrymore show that means it's time for
a cookbook countdown
we are eagerly counting down the days
until our debut cookbook is released on
november 2nd
that's right
[Music]
and
today we're tackling a meal that's also
one of my favorite
meals period that's actually in the
cookbook
and it's for
a meal that i think has a reinvention
and sometimes you can get stuck in a rut
because it's breakfast
so i love this we have a busy mom and
dad with us who wrote into our show
about their breakfast needs and a bit of
a revamp i am feeling you alice and
jimmy hi
but more importantly today is a very
special day for both of you
yes it is it's our nine-year wedding
anniversary
what better way to spend it um
we've been uh married well we've been
married nine years we've been together
12 years we have two little boys seven
and four no
oh i have seven and nine oh we're in it
so i know yes
yeah it's it's so chaotic in the house
like we didn't even say happy
anniversary until we got to the show and
we're like
oh it's our anniversary this is why
we're here right isn't it
i i so relate to that i can't even tell
you i mean it's i'd like to call it the
beautiful mess it is you know the
beautiful chaos and alice and jimmy um
what is your current breakfast routine
no routine
amazing race every day butter toast
plain simple boring fast and then i'll
make jimmy a smoothie i'll eat
whatever's left over yeah we would love
to have a dish that we could make
together on the weekends enjoy together
that's not boring um something exciting
bring the kids into it
um so yeah we we're really looking to
spruce it up so the recipe today and
again we're really honored that you guys
are celebrating with us because this is
actually a recipe i think that was one
of the firsts that we developed together
in the book
um and it's a soft scrambled eggs with
yuzu kosho and a side crisp avocado
salad this is a really easy go-to recipe
so easy it's super simple it takes you a
little bit outside of like your pantry
um but it delivers huge flavor and you
can have this ready in under 10 minutes
so that's really really easy and simple
and this magical recipe and we even have
a photograph because uh there's 300
personal photographs that lauren i took
in the book as well as beautiful
existing artwork
but
this ingredient is yuzuko shu so yuzu
kosho is a japanese condiment and do you
guys like heat do you guys like chilies
oh perfect right up your alley then
because this is made with the yuzu
citrus a little bit of salt and then
some chilies so it has this really nice
heat but it's not very forward it's not
like burn your mouth off
and this thing this condiment is
actually really easy to get you know a
lot of your larger supermarkets will
carry it these days or you can order it
online so it's very accessible once you
know about it you're like oh great it'll
change your life you put it in
everything it's unbelievable it's the
most unique flavor that i have found
inside of a jar in a very long time all
right so
two components to this recipe the first
thing we're gonna make is actually the
salad so in here drew we have some
mayonnaise a little bit of lime juice
and then a little bit of sriracha for
the heat just really lovely i'm going to
give that a quick taste
i'm going to add a little bit of salt to
that a little pepper so that's your
dressing and honestly that dressing will
go
spread it on anything you want and it
will be so freaking delicious
um
next up we're going to add our crunchy
bits like what drew was talking about
you know you have the soft eggs you want
stuff that has a lot of crunch
drew loves iceberg lettuce who here is a
fan of iceberg lettuce
nothing peeves me more than when they
serve me wilted masculine greens i'm
like i want a 1980s
iceberg lettuce salad
i want crunch
[Music]
but don't give me that limp mulch and
tell me i'm supposed to be excited about
it because i'm not
iceberg iceberg lettuce i'm a fan
celery so what i like to do when you're
using raw celery is actually to peel it
before you cut it because celery can be
really tough and stringy and if you're
eating it raw there's nothing worse than
getting some celery stuck in your teeth
so i just do a quick peel with a
vegetable peeler remove the tough outer
fibers i'm learning something right now
you peel those fibers off no wonder
everything tastes so amazing and then it
has a little bit of avocado so you have
that good creamy fat which is really
nice so the salad design we're going to
walk away from that and we're going to
move on to the second component which is
the soft scrambled eggs with the yuzu
kosho so we're going to do two eggs per
person
yes
and then we're going to season that up
with half a teaspoon of yuzu kosho and
then drew i'm going to do as i always do
a little citrus zest in this case a
little lime zest so again you know these
are sort of simple things you can
incorporate into your breakfast routine
that hopefully shake things up that
aren't that complicated also zesting and
garnish are those things that are so
restaurant level and
these little things make such a
difference
absolutely
how you doing over there
excellent beautiful
i didn't mean to but then
all right
well you're just gonna whisk it until
it's frothy and homogeneous like it
looks a little bit paler in color you
want that yuzu and zest incorporated
incorporate it fold it folded and
emulsified so a couple of key points to
remember when you're doing soft
scrambled eggs they're really easy to
make you need a non-stick pan that's
like the first thing and then you want
your heat actually on a medium low so
i'm gonna put a little bit
of i think this is avocado oil that's
probably like which is good oil nice and
neutral basically and then you're gonna
swirl it
around the pan so what are you gonna do
is basically give it a whisk we're gonna
pour into that pan
so i can see your eggs they're starting
to set you'll see in the corners like
the outer corners first and basically
drew you're gonna move in those eggs the
key to soft scrambled eggs low and slow
keep that spatula moving and as you see
i'm also moving my pan
and then drew right where your eggs are
right now you'll see they're a little
wet we're going to pull them off the
heat and they're going to continue to
cook
off the heat in that pan that's the
other thing to remember when you guys
are like attempting breakfast like
what's a dinner time routine are you
take out are you
like order in do you cook then too it's
a little more sane because we've had the
day to think about it and the kids are
you know home and awake you know um
but
yeah i mean we we try to mix it up i'd
say it's like half and half well the
kids eat frozen nuggets and fish sticks
so that makes the work yeah it happens
uh shall we eat while we discuss i'm
really curious to know what you guys
think just delicious
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
no more no more overcooked eggs
perfectly scrambled and it's salty and
tart and spicy
i can feel it in my throat right now
totally awake
and i can't stop shoving the food in my
face
and i just love it so much and i hope
that you guys too and we got you an
anniversary gift actually
the traditional gift um
is uh it is pottery for year 9.
um so we got you a couple's lesson
um so you can get down and dirty with
clay i just went straight to ghosts
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i i love that scene and you know as
parents how often do you get to like get
out and away it must be very challenging
this is our first time
in 19 months as doing a mom and dad date
yeah so thank you for having us
[Applause]
the importance of what you guys said
earlier you hadn't said happy
anniversary to each other until you got
here
in a space where you could just relax
and get in the passenger seat and cruise
for a little while and you have a very
busy demanding life and it's totally
relatable
and i'm so glad that you could have a
moment and you deserve it and get your
pottery on and i'm gonna send you out
for a special night i don't care if i
have to find that babysitter myself
i will um and we're gonna send you to
your favorite restaurant and do it all
up thank you i just want to set you guys
up for a fabulous fabulous memorable
evening that you have earned and
deserved thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
are you juggling everything how do you
do it i don't know
but um
oh thanks for topping off for dave keeps
the pressure off now we don't have to
plan anything else
[Laughter]
i am going to plan everything i am going
to metaphorically
help you have a wonderful day and tuck
you in at night and you babysit you be
apart metaphorically i said
alice you'll be crying real tears if i'm
really in that bedroom it's going to get
weird
maybe i ask like what the burst of
emotion is i'm just curious of them all
oh my gosh someone being so nice to us
and taking care of us for once
in the audience
[Applause]
i'm a choir
by the way that's what moms do we're
criers she does so much for us at home
and um honestly it's just
um i i couldn't make it without her
i know our kids i know our kid's gonna
either i know our kids cannot um so
she is our rock
a lot just watches
at nine years you are respected admired
and called the rock
that's so wonderful
happy anniversary you guys i'm so glad
and grateful that we could be a part of
this memory
[Applause]
thank you very much so much thank you
you rebel homemaker comes out soon who
know
thank
cares we'll see you in a minute
[Music]